[Música]
cómo
yo estudié ingeniería soy ingeniero
químico y el ser ingeniero químico me
planteó muchos retos en la vida uno de
ellos fue cómo ejercer siendo mujer en
la empresa y eso de ejercer siendo mujer
en la empresa me creó muchísimos retos
en la vida uno de ellos
porque me decía mi jefe cómo te va a
obedecer
los los obreros y se me planteó que hay
que enfrentar esos retos porque los
retos se forman como persona y más como
profesional
ahora yo dirijo las evalúa todas las
ingenierías de mexico
soy la directora general del consejo que
evalúan las ingenierías de mexico y no
sólo de mexico no también del extranjero
y esto me lleva a plantearnos un reto
que estamos viviendo en este momento y
que incide directamente en la educación
yo quiero que veamos algo de lo que en
nuestro contexto es común les parece
común esto que estamos viendo donde
hablamos de alta tecnología
ahora vemos uber
nos podemos trasladar en helicóptero en
méjico autodirigido y cuesta 2500 pesos
el traslado
podemos comunicarnos con las personas
inclusive usando pues la televisión o el
internet podemos transportarlos de un
lado a otro en las bandas que caminan
por nosotros y todo esto que nosotros
vemos y que nosotros vivimos alrededor
se llama
industria 4.0 es decir esto se conoce
como la cuarta revolución industrial
y la cuarta revolución industrial
ustedes dirán bueno hubo tres
revoluciones antes donde empezó la
imprenta hasta la revolución actual pero
la cuarta revolución industrial tiene
una gran diferencia con las otras
y yo quiero empezar reflexionando con
ustedes algunos de ustedes vio la serie
de los supersónicos
verdad que sí y la serie se formó se
diseñó para en 1946
para el mundo del 2000 46
recordemos que vivimos en la serie de
los supersónicos se acuerdan cómo se
transportaban los supersónicos en las
bandas
y eso es una realidad hoy se acuerdan
como la casa se encendía y se apagaba
con las palmas y eso es una realidad hoy
se acuerdan cómo se comunicaban
telefónicamente era por vía de
televisión y eso es una realidad el día
de hoy
lo que estaba pronosticado para el 2000
46 es una realidad hace 20 años en
méxico algunas de las cosas se
adelantaron 50 años y esto es industria
4.0 y esa palabra cuando hablamos de
industria 4.0 tenemos que hablar de que
el impacto de esta industria nos va a
pegar en la formación de profesionales
y cuando hablamos que nos va a pegar en
la formación de profesionales
estoy pensando que por ejemplo muchas de
las actividades que hace un profesional
actual van a ser suplidas por una
máquina
por ejemplo todo aquel balance que
hacían los contadores ahora lo haces con
un clic
todavía esa búsqueda que hacían los
abogados ahora lo haces con un clic
todo el operativo que se hace en las
empresas ahora lo hacen las máquinas
es decir
formación
y la industria 4.0 están vinculadas
porque el impacto de la industria 4.0 va
a desaparecer aquellas profesiones que
son operativas y las los profesionales
van a realizar aquellas donde el
pensamiento la argumentación y el diseño
son relevantes y no sólo nos impacta en
la educación nos impacta en la salud nos
impacta en la cultura nos impacta en el
arte nos impacta en la economía es decir
la industria 4.0
está indicando que los profesionales del
futuro deben desarrollar nuevas
competencias más prácticas que nos
permitan que todo ese conocimiento que
adquirimos lo podamos aplicar en
contextos diferenciados y de
incertidumbre es decir cuando nosotros
hablamos de la industria 4.0 la
situación que estamos observando es muy
interesante la tecnología la velocidad
del rayo pero la educación sigue en el
mismo tenor pero el problema es que la
brecha que se está formando entre la
formación y el desarrollo tecnológico
cada vez es mayor
el profesional que requiere la industria
4.0 requiere nuevas competencias
requiere para enfrentar la tecnología
nuevas competencias que a veces en la
escuela la descuidamos por ejemplo como
estudiantes muchas veces uno dice es que
el profesor no sabe por qué no me
explico
y esto es que quieres como estudiar
información
léela en un libro
para eso está la información información
haz clic en internet y vas a leer
muchísima información pero lo que te
tiene que desarrollar la la escuela son
competencias para discriminar aquella
información que es relevante de la que
no es relevante
y esas son las competencias que requiere
la industria 4.0 que es lo que necesita
que formemos en los jóvenes la industria
4.0 la primera es
aquellas competencias que me permitan
que esa información la puedo aplicar en
distintos contextos para resolver
problemas
esa es la primera cosa que nos debe
desarrollar la escuela la segunda todas
aquellas competencias que muchas veces
le llamamos genéricas o transversales
los educadores que eso que no se forman
con una asignatura por ejemplo
la comunicación asertiva
la comunicación efectiva la comunicación
efectiva que no solo es escrita es oral
y tecnológica pero como una competencia
se tiene que desarrollar con la práctica
y poner a un estudiante a hacer defensa
de un tema no es desarrollar de la
competencia comunicación la
argumentación
otra de las competencias que son claves
es poder identificar y resolver
problemas complejos y ustedes pregunten
qué es un problema complejo
un problema complejo es resolver algo
considerando el impacto de lo que estoy
haciendo y de la solución es decir si yo
soy ingeniero
y yo voy a promover un proyecto del agua
por ejemplo para yucatán
es el impacto en las comunidades de
donde yo ponga la empresa cuál es el
impacto social cuál es el impacto
económico es decir es más caro hacer eso
que otra cosa cuál es el impacto
ambiental y eso es decir
y resolver problemas complejos
cuando a veces lo que a uno lo que
fomentamos en la escuela es resolver
problemas desde el enfoque técnico y no
considerando sus impactos tanto social
económico y ambiental
otras de las competencias que son claves
en este momento y que muchas veces los
estudiantes menospreciamos
las habilidades para el marketing las
habilidades para la gestión eso no lo va
a poder ser una máquina
y en las carreras en mexico
tristemente yo voy a hablar de la
ingeniería pero puedo hablar de todas
el área de ciencias
económico-administrativas con ese
enfoque está desapareciendo cuando en
otros países como canadá que presentaron
hace un rato el caso de canadá la
ingeniería económica es obligatoria para
todas las carreras para tomar decisiones
óptimas considerando su impacto es decir
las competencias que se requieren en el
futuro son diferentes a las que estamos
fomentando en la escuela no olviden que
si seguimos así la brecha entre la
escuela y el mundo de trabajo se va a
ser cada vez mayor
lo que es operativo
va a ser sustituido por una máquina
es decir veamos
carreras como contaduría
todos esos cálculos que hacen los
contadores ahora lo haces clic y lo hace
haciendo
ya ni siquiera lo hacen los contadores
los contadores namasté analiza por qué
haciendo ya nos tiene amarrados entonces
esas estas nuevas ideas lo que nos tiene
que ayudar es a reflexionar
como padres de familia como maestros y
como jóvenes que estamos poniendo
nuestra vida y apostando la por tener
una mejor calidad de vida en fomentar
aquellas habilidades que son necesarias
para el mundo que viene
es decir hay tres ideas fundamentales
lo que es operativo va a ser sustituido
por una máquina
lo que es el talento y la inteligencia
va a ser papel del hombre
la argumentación no la puede hacer una
máquina la tiene que ser el hombre el
diseño lo tiene que hacer el hombre no
la máquina por ejemplo
ahora tú te vas a poder diseñar el
vestido y la tecnología 3-d te va a ser
el vestido que te va a quedar
perfectamente bien ya no voy a requerir
un diseñador de modas ni voy a requerir
una costurera porque yo voy escojo mi
material lo meto a la máquina 3d y el
vestido me va a quedar perfecto se están
construyendo casas en 24 horas usando la
tecnología 3-d
en la universidad de pensilvania
entonces
pensemos cómo cambia el mundo y el
impacto que tiene la tecnología en
nuestra vida cotidiana y en nuestra vida
como estudiantes
y esto también tenemos que hacer un
segundo punto de reflexión el talento
emprendedor el emprendedurismo y la
creatividad van a ser factores claves
para los jóvenes para que subsistan en
el futuro pero esto también nos impacta
en una segunda forma las metodologías
que usamos para que nos enseñen tendrán
que cambiar en esta industria 4.0 la
tecnología y la metodología básica para
aprender esa metodología básica es
basada en resolución de casos y
proyectos reales que te permitan
desarrollar y argumentar una solución
yo quisiera terminar porque
cuando tú ves que algo viene y que es
inevitable lo que viene tienes que
seleccionar lo mejor para poder tener
una mejor calidad de vida
a mí me gustó mucho cuando alguien dijo
si el cuerpo no responde pon a funcionar
tu mente
yolo aterrizaría a otra cosa
yo diría
si la escuela no funciona
pone a funcionar tu mente porque el
mundo que viene de alta tecnología
requiere un profesional diferente y tú
mereces tener una mejor calidad de vida
y tú y la vida que tú quieres depende de
ti muchas gracias
[Aplausos]